Ha fallecido el comandante presidente
Hugo Chávez el 5 de marzo de 2013 entre
lágrimas el entonces vicepresidente
Nicolás Maduro ponía fin a las
especulaciones y confirmaba la muerte de
Hugo Rafael Chávez frías víctima de un
cáncer a los 58 años conocido por sus
seguidores como el comandante fue una
figura polarizante que tras su llegada
al poder en 1999 inició una
transformación económica social y
política con efectos aún presentes en
Venezuela pu
ro adelante juro
delante de mi pueblo
que sobre esta moribunda constitución
de cumplir
impulsaré las transformaciones
democráticas necesarias para que la
República nueva tenga una carta magna
adecuada a los nuevos tiempos lo juro el
socialismo del siglo XXI fue su política
insignia Durante los 15 años que estuvo
en la silla presidencial con la
nacionalización de industrias como la
petrolera multiplicó los subsidios para
programas sociales y cambió radicalmente
la comunicación política hablándole
directamente al pueblo con sus cadenas y
dándole voz con su Aló presidente cada
domingo favorecido por la chequera
petrolera no dudó en criticar el sistema
económico mundial y en retar a figuras
poderosas que contradecían sus ideas
ayer estuvo el
aquí en este mismo lugar huele a azufre
todavía
esta mesa
donde me ha tocado hablar criticado por
sus posturas mesiánicas por sus
expropiaciones y por el cierre de medios
de comunicación críticos muchos lo
señalan como responsable de haber
sentado las bases de un modelo que
llevaría Venezuela a la crisis tras la
caída de los precios del petróleo desde
el intento de golpe de estado de 1992
Chávez llegó al imaginario político
venezolano para quedarse 10 años después
de su muerte lo que muchos auguraron no
se produjo el chavismo sigue vivo
convertido en icono para millones desde
la tumba Hugo Chávez sigue Gozando de un
56% de aprobación segunda tan análisis